فد كيف تبدو الاوضاع الانسانيه في فلسطين
بينما نتحدث الان لا كهرباء لدى اهالي غزه
انقطع التيار الكهربائي عن قطاع غزه بسبب
توقف محطه توليد الكهرباء الوضع الانساني
سيء جدا كان معنا منذ قليل لعدنان ابو
حسنه المسؤول في منظمه غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين تحدث عن 50 مدرسه
يمكن ان تاوي اللاجئين الفلسطينيين وهي
تستوعب 100 50,000 لاجئ فلسطيني لكن من
وصل الى حد الان الى هذه المدارس يبلغ نحو
2000 مواطن فلسطيني وصلوا الى هذه المدارس
بعد خمسه ايام من القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل على القطاع وعدنان ابو حسنه يقول
بان امكانات وكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
محدوده جدا والسبب في ذلك هو الحصار
المفروض على القطاع على الجانب الاخر ايضا
هنالك حاله من الهلع هنالك بعض من
الاسرائيليين من يتركون البلاد ويسافرون
الى الخارج والبعض الاخر يقومون بتخزين
المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه خوفا من الاتاتي
ايضا هنالك دعوات للقرى الموجوده قرب
الجولان لبقاء سكانها قرب الملاجئ اذا وضع
صعب على الجانبين الجميع متخوف مما سياتي
في الايام المقبله ولكن الوضع الانساني في
قطاع غزه حرج جدا في ظل الحصار المفروض
على هذا القطاع